أنا مهتم بمحاولة اكتشاف
الكمال من خلال أخذ شيء مألوف
والنظر إلى هذا الكائن من خلال
عيون الآلة
[الموسيقى]
يتناسب مشروع البحيرة مع
البحث المستمر الذي أجريته على
القطع الأثرية الكلاسيكية ، إنه حقًا رمز
الكمال الذي كانت العملية عليه
ركز أولاً على إعادة إنشاء نموذج رقمي
للبحيرة ، فأنا في الأساس لا
أصمم منحوتة أصمم نوعًا
من تسلسل الإحداثيات ،
فأنا على وشك إنشاء رسم متحرك لهذا
التسلسل من الإحداثيات التي
تحتاج الروبوتات إلى اتباعها ، نستخدم روبوتًا  هذه
آلة قياسية تُستخدم في العديد من
الصناعات المختلفة ،
لم تلمس يدي النحت في النهاية
حيث نوجه هذا الروبوت إلى ما نريد
أن يفعله هذا الروبوت هو تدخلي
باعتباره شيئًا رائعًا قاله مايكل أنجلو
هو أن التمثال  كان
بالفعل في الكتلة ، لقد كان ببساطة
يزيل الحجر المحيط به
، فأنا في الغالب أستكشف المسافة
بين الكتلة الأصلية للمادة
والبحيرة التي  ght يكون بالداخل